se nos pide que probemos que el
triángulo a de c es congruente con el
triángulo bs y nos dicen que la figura
no está escala nunca asuman que así está
y hay algo que nos proporcionan aquí nos
dicen que el segmento ac es congruente
con el segmento b se hace es congruente
con veces y que el segmento cde es
congruente con c
es decir aquí lo marco de diferente
manera porque no necesariamente el
segmento de s tienen la misma longitud
que el segmento ac pero lo que nos dicen
es que se ve es congruente con c
por eso la marcamos así qué más podemos
encontrar al respecto de esta figura
para poder decidir si ese triángulo es
congruente con este otro bueno una cosa
que sí sabemos es que este ángulo de
aquí el ángulo acd es congruente con el
ángulo bs.f este de acá vamos a
escribirlo a c
y aquí no lo parece pero estamos
hablando de ángulos este ángulo es
congruente con el ángulo bc y podemos
decir que esto es así porque los ángulos
verticales son iguales
muy bien ahora ya tenemos esto en forma
de agua y creo que para esta suficiente
información para decir que estos no son
congruentes podemos decir que el
triángulo a de s
adc es congruente con el triángulo de s
v s y sabemos eso porque tenemos un lado
un ángulo y otro lado aquí tenemos el
mismo lado el mismo ángulo y el mismo
otro lado nuestras razones lado ángulo
la l l
a veces se tarda un poquito esto en
responder pero para mi suerte a está
respondiendo bastante rápido y creo que
con esto ya hemos terminado vamos a
checar nuestra respuesta le damos click
aquí y si una carita feliz fue respuesta
correcta